مدينه غامضه من احد عشر طابقا شيدت تحت
الارض اساطير قالت انها بنيت من قبل الجن
واخرى وصفتها بالحصن الحصين لسكان بلده
كبادوكيا التركيه فتلك المدينه كانت ملاذ
السكان من الهجمات العسكريه عليهم انها
مدينه ديرين كويو في العالم السفلي
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
عام
1963 تم اكتشاف اغرب ارث بشري تحت الارض
في العالم مدينه باكملها تم نحتها قبل
الاف السنين في باطن احجار بركانيه لينه
المدينه عباره عن ممرات تشبه المتاهه
ابوابها كما تشير الدراسات التاريخيه كانت
مجهزه باحجار ضخمه من الخارج تتم دحرجتها
عند الشعور بالخطر او هجوم الاعداء فيتم
اغلاق ابواب تلك المدينه في قاع الارض
ليحتمي اهلها داخلها تحفه معماريه من احد
عشر طابقا على عمق نحو 60 مترا وملاذ امن
يستوعب بين عشرين وثلاثين الف شخص عند غزو
الغزاه واشتداد وطيس المعارك على الارض
يا شمس
رياضه
هندسه مدينه ديرين كويو صعبه ودقيقه
للغايه فالبناء والنحت تم من دون وجود
اعمده سانده الحفر تم في صخور اللينه لكن
العجيب انها كانت تحوي قنوات للمياه
الجوفيه ومداخل منفصله وفيها بعض الاعمده
للتهويه وبعض الممرات المتصله بعضها ببعض
لكن المفاجاه الكبرى هي العصور ايضا على
اماكن فيها مخصصه كاسطبلات للماشيه واماكن
لتخزين النبيذ واماكن للصلاه واماكن
للحراسه
المؤرخون والعلماء اختلفوا حول من بنى
مدينه ديرنكويو الغامضه وكيف امكن للبشر
العيش وتكيف تحت سطح الارض بنحو 60 مترا
ولهذا يعتقد البعض انها احدى مدائن الجن
من
ذهب
تشير المصادر من وزاره الثقافه التركيه
الى ان بعض الشعوب القديمه في القرنين
السابع والثامن قبل الميلاد كانت تجيد
بناء الكهوف في باطن الصخور وتحت الارض
وان مدينه الجن او مدينه ديرنكويو فتشكلت
في الحقبه البيزنطيه وكان هدفها حمايه
السكان من خطر الحروب المحيطه بمنطقه
كابادوكيا انذاك التي كانت محاطه بالفرس
في الشرق واليونانيين
الغرب والاشوريين في الجنوب والبنتوس في
الشمال ولهذا السبب اندلعت اكبر الحروب في
المنطقه مدينه ديرنكويو تعتبر احدى اكبر
عجائب الدنيا وسرا يرفض الافصاح عن خلاياه
فلم يتم الجزم حتى الان بمن بناها وشيدها
او ما الغرض من انشائها كل التفسيرات التي
قيلت تبقى مجرد اجتهادات من علماء الاثار
والتاريخ لكن الحقيقه انها شاهد اخر على
عبقريه الانسان في ذلك الزمان